The jogan Experience I'm drawing a blank
on the term but what is it called when
your body uh sets its time for the day
from the Sun yeah circadian rhythm
supposed to be great for that so it it
benefits your sleep a lot right to to
get sunlight early in the morning yeah
supposedly sets your body's clock your
mind's clock I've never had a problem
with sleep yeah me neither luckily I'm
just one of those guys I suck suck yeah
I have friends that really struggle with
sleep my wife struggles with sleep I I
can go to sleep on a [__] train
station floor I don't get it at all and
I I'm not super empathetic about it too
cuz sometimes like my wife will be up
like doing something in the middle of
the night and she's like she can't sleep
and I'm like what are you doing like go
back to sleep she's like you think I
want to yeah some people just can't
sleep well jao only sleeps like four
hours a night dude that's not good for
you he says he doesn't need anymore yeah
but his brain does I don't know I don't
know maybe not like for functioning
right now but like long term like you
ask Andrew hberman and that's one of the
things you can do to like help your
brain function as long as possible and
like with Alzheimer's and all kinds of
brain issues like long term sleep is a
major factor yeah it's a major factor if
they look at the correlation between
like the amount of hours of sleep and
the instances of Alzheimer's it seems to
be some sort of a connection huge yeah I
don't know joo's a different kind of
animal though maybe he's definitely
seems built different yeah maybe he just
doesn't need it as I think there's
certain people I think Arnold is one of
those people too Schwarzenegger I think
he said only sleeps a few hours a night
yeah I think there's certain people that
just like they have just different
requirements there there are people that
like physically don't need as much sleep
like everybody needs some sleep but I
think there are people I'm not one of
them I can notice the difference between
six and eight hours I know it's a big
difference six hours I'm like I got to
push there an extra push whereas eight
hours good to go yeah you know I sleep
six or seven hours a night but I feel
like everybody's different like there
there must be outliers to to only sleep
four hours a night and function well it
must not affect your hormones as much as
most people because like I feel like
most people if you sleep four hours a
night it's terrible for your hormones
causes crazy crash in your hormones dep
I think it really depends on what you're
doing like for some people like if
you're only sleeping four hours but your
job is very engaging and very intense
and there's a lot of adrenaline you're
fired up like at the end of that day
you're probably going to crash hard but
you might be able to pull it off and
keep going but if you have like some
[__] paperwork job and you only slept
like four hours you're going to be
yawning and falling asleep you're going
to be barely able to get through it or
even this job there's like the brain the
brain function aspect you know oh here
it is huge after 10 years search
scientists find second short sleep Gene
after a decade of searching UC see San
Francisco scientists who identified the
only human gene known to produce natural
short sleep lifelong nightly sleep that
lasts just say four to 6 hours yet
leaves individuals feeling fully rested
have discovered a second uh it says
before we identified the first short
sleep sleep Gene people really excuse me
really weren't thinking about sleep
duration in genetic terms said Ying hu
Fu uh PhD professor of Neurology and
member of the
UCSF uh whale we how do you say that
wheel wheel wheel Institute for
neurosciences Fu led the research team
that discovered both short sleep genes
the newest of which is described in a
paper published August 28th 2019 the
Journal of neuron according to Fu many
scientists once thought that certain
sleep behaviors couldn't be studied
genetically sleep can be difficult to
study using the tools of human genetics
because people use alarms coffee and
pills to alter their natural sleep
cycles she said these sleep disruptions
the thinking went made it difficult for
researchers to distinguish between
people who naturally sleep for less than
6 hours and and those who do so only
with the aid of an artificial stimulant
and natural short sleepers remained a
mystery until 2009 when a study
concluded conducted rather by foo's team
discovered that people who had inherited
a particular mutation in a gene called
dec2 averaged only 6.25 hours of sleep
per night study participants lacking the
mutation averaged
8.06 hours the
finding provided the first conclusive
evidence that natural short sleep is is
at least in some cases genetic but this
mutation is rare so while it helped
explain some natural short sleepers it
couldn't account for all of them
interesting yeah that is interesting you
but I think Joo is just an animal yeah
just must very I think he likes being
tired I think he likes waking up tired
and then pushing through it his he he's
probably so used to suffering on a daily
that that just becomes his Baseline if
he's not suffering he probably doesn't
feel right yeah right well how many
[__] go to his Instagram how many
photos is there of his watch at 4:30 in
the morning got the worst best best
Instagram but the worst Instagram you're
just like another watch photo but you
know he's getting after
it